Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Avete mai salvato la vita a una persona?
Chi di voi sa farlo?
C'era una stanza, all'ultimo piano
della casa di mia nonna,
in un paese di montagna,
non troppo distante da qui.
C'erano stoffe di tanti colori
e materiali diversi,
strumenti di vario tipo
ed enormi fogli bianchi,
sui quali prendevano vita modelli
che partivano da curve
a me incomprensibili.
Era il laboratorio di mia mamma.
Una sarta.
E io da bambina amavo andarci spesso,
per osservare in silenzio
come lei riuscisse a dare vita
alle sue creazioni,
dalla carta alla stoffa.
Misurando, tagliando, cucendo,
provando, riprovando,
ripetendo questi passi
in maniera a volte non lineare,
fino a quando il modello
non calzava perfettamente
sul fisico e sulla corporatura
della persona per la quale
era stato creato.
Ecco: io oggi posso dire
di fare lo stesso.
Solo che al posto della stoffa
uso la matematica.
Il mio ago e il mio filo sono un computer,
e i modelli li costruisco sui dati,
che per quanto grezzi e imperfetti
sono ricchi di informazione.
"Su che cosa? " vi starete chiedendo.
Su quelli che sono
gli attori delle epidemie,
Ovvero: un virus; le persone;
alle volte un insetto,
come ad esempio le zanzare;
e l'ambiente in cui
questi interagiscono tra di loro.
Per lavoro e per passione,
studio le epidemie,
usando modelli matematici e statistici
che mi permettano di rispondere
a domande del tipo:
con che velocità
si sta diffondendo il virus?
Quanti infetti può causare,
questa epidemia?
E che impatto potrebbe avere un vaccino?
E talvolta i modelli
mi permettono di prevedere,
ovvero anticipare, quello
che potrebbe succedere in futuro.
Mi avreste creduto
se a metà gennaio vi avessi detto
che un nuovo coronavirus,
di origine animale,
avrebbe infettato più
di 22 milioni di persone
e avrebbe fatto quasi 800.000 morti?
Sono sicura che nei mesi scorsi
vi sarete chiesti, almeno una volta:
"Quando finisce
questa emergenza?
Quando torneremo alla normalità,
alla nostra vita che vivevamo
fino allo scorso gennaio?"
E se vivete in Italia,
o come me in Gran Bretagna,
due paesi colpiti
molto duramente dal COVID-19,
o in altri paesi che sono riusciti
a piegare la curva epidemica,
probabilmente vi starete anche chiedendo:
"Il peggio lo abbiamo alle spalle,
o ci sarà una seconda ondata?".
Questo che ho in mano
è un chicco di riso.
Immaginiamo che sia una persona infetta.
Ogni persona infetta
ne contagia altre tre:
il numero di infetti cresce
di generazione in generazione,
seguendo una legge esponenziale.
Se contiamo il numero di infetti
in dieci generazioni,
vediamo che questo numero sale da uno,
poi tre, nove, 27, 81 e così via.
Nel giro delle prime cinque generazioni,
passiamo da uno a 243.
243 grani ci stanno
comodamente in una mano.
E se ciascuno di questi grani
fosse un infetto,
riempiremmo un aeroplano.
Nel giro delle seconde cinque generazioni,
quindi nello stesso arco temporale
nel quale siamo passati da uno a 243,
passiamo da 243 a più di 59.000.
Che sono tanti così.
Ovvero, avremmo un numero di infetti
tanto grande da riempire uno stadio.
Quando un nuovo virus emerge,
il numero di casi cresce sempre
in maniera esponenziale:
ovvero, all'inizio molto lentamente;
e a un certo punto esplode.
Una curva epidemica ha, più o meno,
il profilo di una montagna.
La salita cresce all'inizio dolcemente:
poi si fa sempre più dura.
Ad un certo punto, dobbiamo
addirittura arrampicare usando le mani.
Ma prima di arrivare
in vetta la salita rallenta:
la crescita esponenziale
non dura per sempre.
Ma quando un'epidemia fa il suo corso,
la discesa comincia
solo quando si è raggiunta
la famosa immunità di gregge.
Questo è uno di quei risultati
della matematica dell'epidemia
dai quali non si scappa.
E fino a quando non avremo raggiunto
questa famosa immunità di gregge,
o con l'infezione naturale, o -
in un futuro speriamo non troppo lontano -
aiutati da un vaccino,
l'emergenza non sarà finita
e l'epidemia può riprendere.
Più contagioso è un virus,
più grande la porzione di popolazione
che deve sviluppare questa immunità,
prima che l'emergenza finisca.
E per il COVID-19, si tratta circa
del 60 - 70 percento della popolazione.
Il problema è che,
oltre a essere molto contagioso,
questo virus causa, anche,
una malattia molto grave, ed è letale
E quindi si è dovuti intervenire.
E ad oggi, si stima
che nemmeno nelle parti
più colpite d'Italia
sia stata raggiunta
questa immunità di gregge:
in realtà se ne è ancora molto lontani.
E quindi, quasi paradossalmente,
siamo lontani dalla fine dell'emergenza
anche se siamo riusciti
a frenare o a fermare l'epidemia,
perché di fatto, il virus non è sparito.
Circola ancora, e lo fa
con la stessa forza di sempre.
Avremo dunque una seconda ondata?
La risposta è: dipende!
Perché i modelli non sono
una palla di cristallo.
I modelli sono uno strumento
che, usando le parole di Robert May,
che è il fondatore
della matematica delle epidemie,
"impone chiarezza e precisione,
rendendo possibile paragonare
in maniera sensata
le conseguenze di semplici ipotesi
con i fatti".
E i modelli permettono
di esplorare scenari,
che sono costruiti sulla base
delle informazioni che abbiamo disponibili
nel momento in cui facciamo l'analisi
e sulla base di ipotesi.
E una delle ipotesi più difficili
da impostare, da prevedere,
è il comportamento umano,
che varia nel tempo e nello spazio
sulla base di moltissimi fattori.
Tra i quali: le informazioni,
che possono essere scientifiche o meno;
le regole sociali;
le nostre abitudini, e la politica.
Ci siamo mai chiesti
come evitare un singolo contagio
può cambiare la traiettoria
di un'epidemia?
Torniamo per un secondo all'esempio
della crescita esponenziale,
ai nostri chicchi di riso.
Spezzare un singolo anello
nella catena di trasmissione
alla prima generazione
può ridurre il numero
dei contagi del 30 percento.
Ovvero, un singolo contagio evitato
può risparmiare fino a 20.000 infezioni
e salvare circa 200 vite.
O anche di più!
Perché in media ciascun infetto
ne contagia altri tre,
ma sappiamo bene che la media
nasconde spesso divari.
E infatti, i dati ci dicono
che un numero relativamente
piccolo di eventi
causa la maggior parte delle infezioni.
Questi eventi, che si conoscono
come fenomeni di "superdiffusione",
avvengono in luoghi di aggregazione,
più frequentemente al chiuso.
Dove non si rispettano
regole semplici e di base, come:
stare a casa ed isolarsi,
se si è malati e si hanno sintomi;
mantenere le distanze;
indossare correttamente una mascherina;
e lavarsi spesso le mani.
Ed è proprio qui
che le scelte e le azioni individuali
vengono ad amplificarsi,
nel bene e nel male.
E hanno il potere, e il potenziale,
di andare a cambiare
la traiettoria di un'epidemia.
I modelli ci dicono che
l'emergenza coronavirus non è finita:
allo stesso tempo, i modelli
e l'evidenza dei fatti ci dicono
che l'epidemia può essere soppressa,
e una seconda ondata evitata.
Ma se questo scenario si avvererà,
dipende fondamentalmente da noi.
Steven Fry, che è un famoso attore
e scrittore britannico,
disse un paio d'anni fa:
"Il futuro è incerto,
anche se dista solo un giorno".
E il destino del mondo sarà determinato
dalla strada che ciascuno di noi
sceglie di percorrere oggi.
Non è il virus, che si diffonde:
sono le persone, siamo noi,
che diffondiamo il virus.
E in situazioni di emergenza,
l'unica cosa che possiamo fare
è scegliere come reagire e come agire.
Consapevoli che ciascuno di noi
ha un ruolo fondamentale,
e può davvero fare la differenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)